hello everyone and welcome back to the
tata steel rapid event of the
Grantchester it's Lebanon vs. Magnus
cross and in round three of the event
it's really really a wild game so I do
hope you enjoy it but before we check
out the game I would just like to invite
everyone to check out a very nice
interview it was done by a shark shark
from chess base India now the interview
he interviewed Magnus Carlsen about well
mostly about Vishwanath on Anand as it's
soon to be which is a 50th birthday now
I think on December 11th will be his
50th birthday and they asked Magnus a
couple of things about him about Rishi
and if he can from memory recognize ten
positions from ten of anons games so
it's a really nice interview I do hope
you enjoy it it will be the first link
you see in the description below it's
it's not very long so I feel free to
check it out if you haven't already now
getting back to the game eleven with the
white pieces opens with E for now we
have c5 by Magnus Knight to f3 we have D
six and now B for C captors and before
we have Knight captures Knight to f6
that's not a knight Knight to c3 and a6
denied or variation is on the board and
it's not not surprising since 11 already
faced tonight or seen a rapid event in
in in Bucharest in Romania in the in the
superb at weapon and blitz he played it
against Geary and Wesley soul so we have
F 3 e 5 pushing the knight back Knight
to b3 and now Bishop to e6 Magnus
continuous development butter up the e3
and in that event we mentioned that both
Wesley in the Giri played the Bishop to
e7 and here we have a knight East Knight
to d7 so Carlsen DV is from the line 11
played against Geary and and Wesley
we have g4 now preparing to further
expand on the King side Bishop to e7 and
Queen to d2 here 11 prepares the
queenside castle
we have castles by black and Queen side
castles by white so here we have castles
on opposite sides its Sicilian neither
of its you know everything you can hope
for in a rapid game between this to such
a great play
so basically it will be a race black
bull attack on the queenside white will
try an attack on the kingside and who
will be faster so b5 Carlsen starts
expanding on the Queen side and the g5
11 does the same on the kingside Knights
to h5 and now King Tubby one always a
useful move we entice the b6 by Magnus
and now comes Knight to a5 for the
moment that there aren't any discoveries
so you cannot move the knight to expose
the attack of the Queen to the knight
here we have rook the c8 Magnus
continues development and now a 3 we
have g6 by Magnus and now cementing this
Knight here also at some point you might
want to move the rope maybe get the
bishop over to g7 if needed with h4 by
11 and now comes Knight the g3 and this
position has been reached in the Prague
Masters Tournament this year between
Davi navara and alpha by taschek yeah
where rook to h2 was played but here
Magnus just trades a rope the g1 is
played by 11 now it's a new move it's
only as a move 17 that we have a
completely new game but Magnus now
trades everything with Knight captures
on f1 rubgy captures on f1 you don't
want to move this rook you need the
control of the D file and now Knight to
a4 offering even more trades now the
threat is just Queen captures a knight
so here 11 grabs the night and a for now
the knight on e5 is defended we have B
cap present a for Magnus ruins his pawn
structure on the Queen side but it's of
little importance as what he really
wants to do is to open lines in front of
the White King with h5 11 continues his
attack on the Queen side and here comes
wind sorry on the King side and here
comes Queen to d7 Queen to d7 is a
crucial defending that well defensive
move because it will guard the h7 point
at some point 11 will bring the rook and
the Queen to the h-file threat and H
captures G and you want to have the h7
point protected and the Queen from d7
will do a nice job of that because after
pawn captures you will capture with the
F pawn exposing the Queen's defense to
the h7 pawn so here 11 goes rook to h1
he continues with his plan we have rook
fe8 makes room for the bishop also you
have to move the bishop if you want the
Queen
Gardi h7 pawn Quinta h2 and now brush up
the f8 and now like we said if captures
captures the Queen nicely defends the h7
pawn a white a white doesn't have an
attack going on anymore so here we have
Bishop to d2 not wanting to transfer the
bishop over here will he'll will help
out with the defense rook the c7 now the
Queen will be able to move as the rook
will also be able to help out with the
defense of the seventh rank with Bishop
to b4 now piling up on the d6 pawn which
is a backwards pawn across and still
didn't have time to push it to d5 we
have rook to b8 adding the other look
into the attack and now rook the d3
preparing to use use it as a defensive
piece along the third-ranked also route
to c3 is an idea at some point with
Queen to b5 by Magnus and here 11 plate
rook the c3 I will just mention that
there is a disgusting engine line that
starts with c4 but it's a rapid game so
we're not going to do well on it for too
long
point of C c4 is that it just kicks the
Queen away because you cannot capture it
if you capture it than just Knight
captures and you cannot capture back
with the rug because of H captures you
need the rook to guard the h7 pawn after
F pawn captures and if Queen captures
then rook c3 just wins the rook after
you move the Queen so after c4 you would
have to move the Queen back and now you
play H captures F captures while the
Queen guards at this point here and now
just go rook H to d1 saying that you
will gladly trade your c4 pawn for the
d6 pawn so this is one way to go about
it but it's a for a rapid game and
unlikely move to happen but okay rook to
c3
we have beat the c8 now doubling up on
the under C file by magnus rook captures
on c7 rook captures and rook to d1 now
again piling up on that d6 pawn and rook
to d7 here Magnus just defends it and
hopes to push d5 one day with rook to d3
by 11 and now Bishop to e7 attacking the
g5 pawn and here H captures and g6 with
F captors and g6 the pawn is not
defended but there is no roof Queen
battery along the H file so it's not a
problem for for the moment
Queen the deed
again with a triple attack on the d6
pawn and now comes Queen to b6 adding
another defender with Queen to c1 and
now comes Bishop to d8 Bishop to d8 a
very nice move which after the Queen
moves you will put pressure now on the
night here but also you're preparing
something else
so here eleven pushes c4 and now comes
Queen to F do just infiltrating with the
Queen and here Knight to c6 attacking
the bishop here but feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the best
move for black it's not an easy move to
find but you know I feel free feel free
to do it while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations as its it's a
magnificent move that starts a brilliant
line and for those who just want to
enjoy its Bishop captures on g5
deflecting the Queen and you want to
deliver a queen to f1 check which will
threaten the rook which will basically
force the king to go to c2 but black has
a light square bishop so when you mix
that all together it kind of works so
here we have Queen captures in g5 it is
the D strongest reply Queen to f1 Czech
threatening to win the rook and now kink
the c2 defending and here Magnus plays
Bishop captures in c4 now threatening
Queen captures on d3 and here xi has to
decide whether he gives up some material
back or does he try to hang on to
everything if you try to hang on to
everything it's well it's just really
difficult for example if Luke the c3 you
get Bishop to b3 check and now you
either have to give up the exchange it
this way or after you move now you get
d5 and now if you if you allow the roof
to open up the D file it's game over
so here you do have an option on how to
how to not open it with the knight to e7
check King to f7 and now you can capture
on d5 because your knight guards the d5
pawn but still after Queen to have to
check King to d3
now you can capture on d5 and well here
after Queen captures I need five it's
just a whole mess of the position in the
end after Queen captures on f3 with
check King before and now Queen back to
f2 check King to d3 and Bishop to b7
check finally open up the the discovery
from the rook you go Bishop to d6
blocking and now white will have Queen
to f6 which will allow him to win back
the piece and well just enjoy being up
two connected passports but it's it's
very hard to calculate of course both of
them are very low on time so neither of
them calculated all of it but both both
11 and the Magnus realized that there is
something there so 11 doesn't even try
to save the rookie goes Queen - III we
have Bishop captures and III with check
Queen captures Queen captures and King
captures and here
Magnus forced a trade where he has a
rook against a knight and the bishop but
what he has is the best past h-bond so
what do you do with a past h1 of course
you push it to Magnus goes h5 with Kim
to e3 11 wants to bring the King closer
to the past pawn King to f7 now Magnus
starts bringing the King into the game
with Bishop to c3 and now comes came to
e6
we have Knights to be four now attacking
the a6 pawn but now g5 Magnus says
that's that's a doubled doubled a pawn
you can have that I'm just gonna
continue pushing my pawn so King to f2
and now comes Luke to f7 threatening a
g4 which will allow the room to just
gobble up the pawn King to g2 getting
our the pin and now g4 nonetheless we
have F captures and g4 and before
recapturing Magnus just pins the pawn he
wants to recapture with the rook and
leave the outside passed pawn so Knight
the d5 by white and now comes Luke
captures and g4 we have King to f3 and
now rook to g1 so now the king is cut
off from the entire G file now Magnus
just wants to push his h-bond to victory
we're King 2f doom and here something
unbelievable happens here Magnus played
rook to g7 and the roof to g7 does not
work group to g7 is the well maybe not
the worst but one of the the worst the
well it's just a bad move and
the reason why it's bad the well I'm
sure you can sport it without even
pausing the video is because it lines up
with the bishop and here Knight to f4
check just picks up the pawn on h5
because if you capture now eleven would
be winning
so after this check you have to move the
King and now it's just the Knight
captures an h5 and without the past H
pawn black doesn't really have
compensation of with the the rook
against a knight and the bishop but
black might still hold but it's gonna be
very difficult problem is after roof to
g.711 did not spot Knight to f4 check he
was very long time he played the King to
f3 but it's also such a weird the
decision I'm sure Magnus had his reasons
probably to garden maybe c7 he didn't
want to allow check or something but
it's a weird decision because whenever
whenever your opponent has a dark square
bishop you will you will always try not
to put your pieces on dark squares even
if there's no immediate danger you will
just have to calculate less especially
if you're a long time so while I'm sure
there's a very good reason where root to
g7 was played it's just a bad move would
work the g8 white is without a movie
just continue pushing your fast point
however 11 played King to f3 he didn't
see Knight to f4 check and now Magnus
just continued pushing the H pawn now
Knight to f4 check doesn't really do
anything because you just moved the King
and there is no point for you to grab
you're just gonna continue pushing the
pawn so after this h4 move we have
Bishop the e1 Magnus continues h3 we
have Bishop to g3 and now rook to b7
sort of a principle of two weaknesses
this is one weakness White has to worry
about to the backwards be two ponies the
other one so here Magnus goes after the
other one Knights the before but now a
five pushing the knight back
Knight to d3 okay the knight defends the
pawn but now rook the b3 preparing to
capture the night you have to defend it
King te 2 and the now comes King to f6
now the King will join join our join
this past pawn and try to escort it with
Bishop to h2 King to g5 knowledge of the
g3 we have King to g4 and now Bishop to
h2 and here Magnus just shows that he's
really really good in the end game he
plays rook
and III allows removes the white king
from the defense of the f3 square and so
the black king can now infiltrate now
the king will come to g2 you can give up
this point for the bishop and here 11
goes a king to d2 which here he tries to
trick Magnus if Magnus goes King to g2
right away then he has King to e2 King
captures on h2 and King f2 and it's a
draw for example King h1 you'll go King
to f1 now h2 you're just gonna go back
into f2 and now black has no moves the
only move black has is d5 you're gonna
go captures now II for these six you're
gonna go III would check King captures
and now you're gonna go King to g2
prepared to bring your queen into the
game these seven eight one Queen and
you'll have d8 Queen and you'll have the
same game where the Queen's are on the
board and with both players having two
points on the Queen side which is a draw
so here Magnus of course not interested
in that he picks up the e4 pawn we have
kinky - and now d5 there are other pawns
to advance we have Bishop to g3 now d4
Bushra back the h2 11 just has to wait
and see what happens we've kink the d5
now King to D 2 and E 4 now we have King
back to e 2 and now King to c4 and here
11 goes Bishop to e5 again allowing
Magnus to make a mistake here d3 would
be a mistake because now you open up the
ship's defense of the pawn here and also
the bishop still covers the h2 square so
here after King to e3
King to b3 yes you still have the two
weaknesses but after King D 2 h2 Bishop
captures you can now just capture the be
do pawn but now the bishop just returns
to d6 guards the a3 pawn and now the
idea 3 phone will block these these two
points and the King will do a very nice
job guarding these two pawns so here
another opportunity for Magnus to go
wrong but he doesn't kink to be three
there's no danger of captures because
you cannot allow h2 so kink the d2 but
now we have d3 now d3 is different
because the king is already on d2 so you
have to make a move so what do you do
here King the d1 was played but now you
get III so you you accomplish something
and you cannot you cannot
something other than the king for
example if you move the bishop this way
then you lose the point if you move the
bishop this way then you allow pawn to
h2 so the bishop cannot move you have to
move the King King d1 now comes a e3 we
have came to c1 and now came to c4 and
it was in this position I'm of 68 death
11 RA and resigned the game and another
excellent victory for Magnus Carlsen
which takes him I believe I don't know
how the first game went I think but we
do have the standings here so we will
check it out and here he just resigns
because now you have to make a move well
e to e one is coming so whatever you
play let's say Bishop d6 you're gonna go
just to bring your King over to let's
say f2 bishop goes back Russia page 2
now you're going to go here and after
let's the King do one king of three
you're gonna go King e1d to check King
d1 and Al King f2 and now there is no
defense against e 2 and E 1 Queen so
after a king to c4 that's that's the
game and here are the standings after
three rounds of rapid so let's check him
out
yeah since you get two points for
winning the rapid Magnus won two games
in rule 1 so he's on five hundred five
out of six so so first lead for Magnus
followed by Nakamura with four other six
then Dingley run and unleash Geary
dhananand pentola harikrishna and we did
gujarati with three out of six followed
by an apology and levin aaron and Wesley
saw with two out of six so that's the
standings after the first day of rapid
but that can change so tomorrow it could
be upside down you know you never know
but the important thing is that you have
to grab as many points in the rapid
section because rapid games are worth 2
points and if you win a blitz game you
only get one point so usually who wins
the rapid the wins basically the Blitz
but it you know it's just anything can
happen so once again that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank David Gill and David [ __ ] for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos serie
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon
continuing the coverage of this knights
tournament checking up on your
suggestion and whatever else happens so
thank you I will see you soon and have a
excellent rest of your day and do check
out the interview with Magnus the first
link in the description below see you
soon